ورغمى تضاربات التي تطال اعداد الشاحنات
المستهدفه في البوكمال ومحتواها لكن
الاجماع يتمثل بضربه اسرائيليه اخرى ساخنه
لايران خلال اقل من 48 ساعه حيث استهدف
الطائرات مسيره قافله شاحنات في منطقه
واقعه تحت سيطره الميليشيات الايرانيه في
البوكمال شرقي سوريا بعد عبورها من العراق
ولم يتضح بعد من يقف وراء الهجوم العدد
المرشح للشاحنات المدمره 6 من اصل 25
شاحنه استهدفت بثلاث غارات بالمسيرات
والتي تقول مصادر سوريا ان الشاحنات تحمل
في الغالب اسلحه لامداد ميليشيات ايران
كون تاثير الانفجار بعد الدرب كان كبيره
القافله كانت قادمه من ايران مرورا من
العراق وبحمايه المليشيات المواليه لايران
كحزب الله العراقي وفقا للمصادر سوريا
وعندها توجهه تلك القافله الى سوريا
وعبودها في حمايه الحارس الثوري ومن
الشيته هناك توقفت الشاحنات في قريه الهرب
في البوكمال السوريه وهناك تم استهدافها
بالمسيرات بالتذكير مشاهدينا معبر القائم
يوسف للمره الايرانيه الذي يؤدي الى سوريا
ولبنان ويشهد كف عاليه من عمليات تهذيب
الاسلحه وايضا مواد البنيه التحتيه
لانتاجها وتجميعها على الاراضي اللبنانيه
والسوريه